what's your advice to actors on finding
their character finding their character
within a certain script or within who
they present as the full person of who
they are the latter the latter okay
um
my advice on that
is to be open to it to really I mean the
cliche is you're enough you are enough
a cliche that's kind of true but it's
only true if what you're presenting is
examined and and nuanced and interesting
um
you know don't
there's there's there's kind of a show
biz life there's a backstage life and
then there's life
and my advice is get involved in life do
something real and
um
you know certain people are just more
inherently interesting than others this
is human nature but to find that
person that is your the core person that
you present that kind of populates
everything
um that just takes time and it takes
patience and it takes
uh
kind of being honest with yourself as to
you know who who you are and and what
you know I
I what did I watch last night I watched
who was it I'm blanking on it now I've
been watching The Morning Show which I
think is so good
and um
oh is this actor I haven't seen him for
a long time he's an older guy named Paul
Guilfoyle who's been in tons of stuff I
haven't seen him in a long time and he's
older than me which means he's really
old
but he's like I went oh that's Paul
gilfoyle wow where has he been but he
just is there I mean he's just he's he
has not only found that thing he's he is
that thing and it's a little bit like
the Jack Warden story that I told I
think
I don't know how you
the advice is just to be open to it and
to be willing to be honest with yourself
about who you are
because that's the whole ball game as
far as
Who You Are
dominates what you can do in in the film
and television world so you really need
to get acquainted with yourself you need
to be you need to like yourself when
people say they don't get me
well maybe they don't get you because
you don't get you
once you start to get yourself people
will start to get you
is it's been my experience but that
takes a long time some people never get
there and some people get there pretty
quickly
what's your advice for finding a
character within the script
when you say finding it you mean
um owning it owning kind of branding it
bringing your own take to what the
director sees well you're in charge of
some of that and there's some of that
you're not in charge of all you can do
is
as my former student said pretend that
what's happening is happening to you
personally all you can do is make it
personal the other stuff you're not in
charge of there's all kinds of
um forces at play that that kind of
subvert that I think that it's it's
knowing
it's kind of also knowing what your
strike zone is everybody's got a strike
zone like by that I mean
not everybody has to have a huge range I
mean I think that is the that is the
the goal of the young actor I can play
everything I can I can do all these
parts I can play an old man even though
I'm not an old man I can play an
Irishman but I'm not Irish they'll get
an Irishman okay they don't need you to
get they'll get an Irishman so I think
understanding who you are and
understanding where you fit and being
okay with that
because otherwise trying to please them
is a Fool's Aaron there's no pleasing
them whoever they are we always talk
about them they don't get it they don't
get me well they don't get you because
you're not present and you're not
bringing yourself to the work and it
sounds complicated it's really simple
but until you make that turn until you
make that pivot as an actor
understanding not just paying lip
service to but understanding that you
are enough
if the you that is presented is fully
examined and interesting
then it becomes easier but otherwise
it's this you know
trying to please them that's what that's
the the on on the tombstone of every
failed actor I tried to please them
does that make sense it does do you
think it happens more with younger
people
uh yes and no I mean it happens younger
people some of them
just are are moving on instincts totally
they don't even understand the subtlety
of that question
some of them so and so they're
blissfully ignorant and sometimes that's
great because lightning strikes you know
they go oh
him
and you don't even know what you don't
even know what you got but you know that
I've seen that happen a lot
but
um
it happens all the time because we want
to please we want to be picked we want
to get the gold star up in the wall
and be told we're good and we want to
get that affirmation and if we didn't
want that we wouldn't be human but we
don't always get that I mean the failure
rate if you can call it that that's a
harsh term is significant I mean how
many things do people audition for and
when do they actually book something
and I see these things on we were
talking about social media earlier
booked it at the beginning on Instagram
and stuff booked it I wanna I wanna have
one says didn't book it
still chill still happy didn't book it
because that's the reality of it
right I mean that is the reality of it
booked it it's like this whole thing of
just presenting this
kind of phony uh confidence and and and
confidence is a hard one thing
and everybody's happy when you books I
mean you know your wife or husband or
your partner everybody's happy when you
get a job because sometimes it's a great
job too
but
um it's that it's knowing who you are
it's it all comes down to that I mean
it's just simple that way for me
how do you know what your character's
flaw is
um
great question I don't know that every
character has a flaw
particularly in film and television when
you're doing more functionary roles
let's say you know that's a really good
question
and I don't know if I have a good answer
for it but I think
there's two things that I I often tell
people to think about that's one of them
and the other one is does your character
have a secret
like what are what are you not saying
sometimes what you're not saying is far
more important than what you're saying
what you choose not to say
uh in a scene like I'm gonna
I'm not going to say that I'm going to
say something different so you you you
watch a character shift Focus so that's
what you choose not to say is very
revealing what the flaw is
sometimes it's real self it's really
evident in the script you know if you're
playing a murderer we know what the flaw
is or we know about the the Baseline of
the flaw is uh but for those more
um
Garden variety roles sometimes they
don't have a flaw in my opinion
if we took that scene where I'm the HR
manager or your Superior writer and
maybe I don't want to let you know that
it's been in your computer so I hey I
need to talk to you so then what what
could something that I how could I
express it without actually saying that
you know we've seen you know online
gambling coming from your computer if I
am holding this secret what's a good
line what's a good way to play it
um
good great question like uh
almost like
um
starting out I think uh not as a
performance evaluation but I just want
to talk to you about you know what's
going on are you happy
things good
good
you know
um
take a look at this does this look
familiar to you
shoved thing
it's mortified
what is that
you're doing that here you're doing that
at home
both places
do you need help
we have HR department
we want to help you because otherwise we
have to remediate this or
we're gonna have to let you go
so I don't know if this is answering
your question but it's it's kind of
understanding
the way in you know the way in is
look if she was a he or she was a
horrible boss and was very
confrontational that's a different scene
entirely if it's if if the motivation of
the boss is I really like this person
here she does a great job I want to try
to remediate this but this is a big
problem that's a different scene
entirely
and it also comes down to what else do
we know about that character what else
do we know about the boss what else do
we know does he or she have uh their own
secret like I don't know if you watched
uh Ted lasso
I haven't watched it great show I hear
good things there was a you know it's
about it's about a football team soccer
team we call it soccer and they had a
they had a sports psychiatrist and and
part of the season
this um African not African-American
African black woman uh in England
and she was just fantastic and and uh
really substantial and then we find out
later on
she got a drinking problem that's very
well hidden so does the act the actor
does the actor have to play that from
the very beginning the actor has a
secret the character has a secret the
character has a substance abuse problem
but the character is also in a position
of authority and reverence she's a
mental health professional
she should be above reproach but she's
not she's a human being so depending of
the vagaries and the subtlety of the
script
you know but some stuff is just cut and
dry and very flat that way B minus
writing is what I call that right
interesting so then I'm sort of
confronting you on your secret but I had
let's say I have a shopping addiction
yeah but I don't want anyone to know
that so I feel uneasy about confronting
you exactly okay interesting yeah